option parce que raphaël avril à lui il
nous a donné sa version c'est plus la
production du pouvoir qui est mise en
cause par max notre témoin vous king
l'eau vous avez fait beaucoup de télé
réalité oui je crois bien c'est à 12 à
oui quand même
c'est comme rafael nadal avec roland
garros si j'avais su ma mère elle allait
le grand chelem là des productions vous
est-ce que vous avez des trucs ce que
vous avez vu des trucs qui vous ont
choqué et qui rejoigne ce qu'a dit
angèle et ses deux amis oui tout à fait
120 personnes alors je vais pas du tout
craché dans la soupe est scandalisé n'y
a pas de souci j'ai su me soigner de ses
blessures et faire la part des choses en
me disant j'ai une qualité d'unique est
pas négligeable sans tout ça ne serait
pas été possible mais j'ai eu les
épaules pour m'en sortir parce que
psychologiquement j'ai quand même été
détruites après le tournage des anges
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pendant ce
temps il ya eu tellement de trucs de
large et était quoi les choses qui vous
ont le plus marqué les choses qui m'ont
le plus marqué c'est que le vocabulaire
j'ai reçu des menaces de mort des
menaces d'agressions de plusieurs
candidats et en fait j'avais mon
téléphone le week-end et je les cacher
dans mon soutien gorge pour avoir des
preuves je me sentais pas protégés par
la production j'allais les voir personne
n'est allé chercher et ben oui mais en
fait il fallait que j'aie des poules je
courais les voir en en dessous à la
production visée remontant où dans la
maison jamais venez me défendre j'ai
peur j'ai d'accord je suis pas en
sécurité d'abbas qui avait lu des
classes c'est comme un compliment quand
tout le monde est enfermé au bout d'un
moment on se classe et ça c'est comme
dans le loft à l'époque où grâce mais ça
oui unsa les téléspectateurs 10 c'est
plutôt normal après voilà qui est des
clash mais des menaces de mort là c'est
un autre délire est très très loin je
vais toujours une maison qui pourrait
pas m'encadrer et donc cgc mais ce
téléphone cacher et la personne qui me
bouscule sans rencontre va prévenir la
prod et quand il récupère nos téléphones
et ben quand je les récupère est le week
end après mes deux téléphones étaient
grillés il ne marchait plus deux iphone
mort j'ai pété un plomb scandale une
rechute un téléphone pour tout détruire
les preuves des menaces que j'avais
enregistrée
d'accord d'accord alors vous avez été
marqué par ça j'étais marqué pas simple
surtout aussi par une grosse crise
d'angoissé que j'ai fait en tournage et
une accumulation à la fin du tournage
les anges
et je tremble et j'arrive plus à
contrôler mon corps j'étais dans un état
mais catastrophique et au lieu de médée
j'avais la preuve devant moi la caméra
devant ma gueule et je disais en émoi
l'hôpital je suis pas bien je peux plus
je peux plus mais c'était une
accumulation là je vous dis ça comme ça
mais c'est super long entourage et
personnes mais des films est comme ça il
me disait rien et il a fallu que mon
corps s'est mis en défense si je me suis
auto calmer tout seul mais des heures
après j'ai cru que j'allais crever